hi I'm Elise from my cupcake addiction
and today I'm gonna foolproof your
frosting I'm gonna show you how to make
all of these really cool techniques with
either star or round piping tips and by
the end of this you're gonna be an
expert I'm actually just gonna snip this
bag off a little bit cuz it's so big
snip off a nice fine tip so your piping
tip won't fall through and then just pop
that hiding tip straight in the bag
pushing all the way down if you have any
trouble filling your piping bags you can
always pop it into a cup or a mason jar
but I generally just fold over the top
and hold my my hand the fold gives the
bag a bit of structure and creates like
a little bit of tension around the
opening always make sure you get these
little air pockets out of your frosting
bags or they'll cause a deliciously
sweet explosion push it down and let any
air out till you see the frosting just
poked out at the end of the tip and then
to seal the bag I'm gonna twist and
fault piping bag prepared if you're just
starting out on your piping journey I
like to do what I call a pipe and what
start your cupcake choose one cupcake
your least attractive of the ball and
you make a mistake
oops not quite right scrape off the
frosting put it back in a bowl and frost
again this helps you get your technique
really spot-on before you go sacrificing
all of your dozen cupcakes and once
you're happy that you've got your wrist
action absolutely perfect and you can
eat this guy for us the rest so for this
one we're gonna do a really simple
almost like a water-type design it works
really well for waves but this is what I
like to call officially spikey dots so
attach the frosting and let it come up
in a nice little peak attach and squeeze
and then pull it up quickly to get that
nice little sharp point on top attach
squeeze and pull attach squeeze and pull
the quicker you pull the sharper the
little point on top I like to make my
little dots a little taller as they get
to the center because more frosting is
always better spiky dots number two we
are gonna do with that
round piping tip this is a sneaky trick
for adding a little bit of height to
your cupcakes without having to go
totally crazy on the frosting not that
there's anything wrong with crazy
amounts of frosting holding my piping
bag still with that twist in place and
then pop down a little dot to glue the
strawberry in place and that gives us
some artificial height
now you can pipe around the outside and
you'll notice that I hold the bag just
slightly higher than the actual cupcakes
that the frosting is really just falling
out nice precise little lines the bigger
the piping tips you can find the easier
your job will be smaller tips require
more precision a larger tips require far
less work to get a perfect well this one
here makes like a really cute little
scalloped or petal technique so I'm
gonna start on one side pipe it dot and
then use the piping bag to drag through
the dot essentially the piping bag is
doing most of the work for us
dot and then in duct and then what so
you lift the bag as you pipe the dot and
then press it down and drag it through
to give it kind of that nice little
comet tail onto our next layer and this
actually looks really beautiful as a
little flower cupcake dot and then swipe
dot and then swipe as you get to the
center ones just make sure that all
coming into the same little point in the
middle and if you want to finish it off
with a little round candy or a gumball
you can all these things we can do with
a round piping tip now a low swirl is
quite different to a high spot because
the highest well we started on the
outside and came in but the low swirl
we're going to start on the center of
the cupcake can come out is a star
piping tip attach your Center star and
then basically circle it but try to keep
your bag pretty straight up and down
again I'm not pressing down I'm actually
ever so slightly lifting that piping tip
all the way around to the outside edges
but we're not done yet because it's all
about the dismount
so as you can't round to this side just
drag that frosting right across so it
just tapers nice
on the side that's a nice looks well it
has that little rose kind of this is
rainbow frosting without a fancy rainbow
frosting maker they actually sell bags
that are divided into three as well but
they're like a dollar of a good we don't
need that so you're gonna take your
first color and you'll see that I'm sort
of smearing it up the side of the bag
using my hand as a bit of support and
then we'll do some yellow like so a
little pink and a little purple so you
have all four colors of your frosting
hanging out in the bag the trick here is
squeezing it all down at about the same
time so watching each of those four
colors
I'm just coaxing them down so that you
get roughly all of them hitting the
piping tip at the same time to make sure
all of your colors are coming through to
a quick test until you see all four this
is an awesome technique if you want just
a couple of colors for a favorite sports
team or if you want to change it up look
at those rainbow colors and again my
piping tip is never touching the
frosting that's falling it's just
slightly above to give us a really nice
amount of height one rainbow cupcake
we're gonna do a dual color frosting
which is one color frosting spread up
one side of the bag and I'm gonna do
purple is our second color spread out
the other side very similar to the
rainbow but just two colors you ever
want to impress anybody do a two or
three color frosting mine's bloom again
pushing them down at about the same time
so we see both colors this is gonna be
like a twist and turn technique so I'm
going to attach on the cupcake pressing
into the cupcake and then I'm gonna
twist to the bag attached right
left and then back again as I stop
squeezing and twist just to disengage
the frosting you can turn the bag here
if you want different shades of pink and
purple on the outside so just give it a
little twist and go again this is a good
example of your hand working at the same
time as your piping bag so I'm gonna
hold my cupcake and I'm actually gonna
use my hand to swell the cupcake around
just slightly as my other hand brings
that frosting swirl with these kinds of
designs that take a little bit longer to
pipe it pays not to have too much
frosting in your piping bag because just
the heat of my hand squeezing that
frosting is actually gonna melt the
frosting up here and then it gets really
difficult to pack with so just put in a
little pipe a couple of cupcakes and
then refill the important thing with
this one is again the dismount so just
stop squeezing and just let it twist so
that you can ensure that as you pull
that frosting away it kind of falls
nicely in the center of the cupcake this
will look cute is a simple little
birthday cake with a little sprinkle on
top of each and a candle in the middle
it's like a tiny birthday cake just for
one that's super cute like everything
practice does make perfect but these
simple tips are gonna up your frosting
game and don't beat yourself up if it
takes you a couple of goes to get your
swirls absolutely perfect these are just
some really basic piping techniques and
we really used to of millions of tips
that you can find get creative
experiment in the kitchen there is no
end to the possibilities when it comes
to upping your piping game when it comes
to decorating the world really is your
cupcake your oyster